[Musique]
vous avez demandé jean christophe averty
de réaliser ce compte
oui par hasard ou parce que vous aviez
vraiment l'intention d'en faire ça c'est
à dire quelque chose de très sophistiqué
sur le plan de la réalisation
mais on savait au départ j'avais pas du
tout le des ambitions aussi grande dans
la mesure où je pensais que c'était
vraiment une parenthèse dans l'intérieur
le fait d'écrire ça et je m'attendais
pas un succès pareil vraiment j'espérais
simplement que le disque père est un
petit peu pour ne pas avoir l'impression
d'avoir en quelques artistes amis dans
une galère puis en fait ça a dépassé
toutes nos espérances
en fait on tendo m'a appelé on me dit ça
serait bien songé si on mettait ça en
images et c'est vrai qu'averti et l
homme rêvait de la situation puisque lui
peut faire voler jeudi en clair c'est le
seul on en a pas vu quelques-uns mais
sait on diffuse pas émis je vis
aujourd'hui ils ont être dur d'attendre
jusqu'à demain il manquait qui nous
manquait c'est ta fausse que j'en oublie
toujours et il me manque et robert
charlebois qui faisait le lapin qui le
fait très bien de manquer le marché dit
qu'ils étaient les ratons laveurs il
manqué isabelle mayereau baleine de
parapluies et puis il ya main yves simon
people petits cailloux si je les oublie
c'est vous et puis oui moi franchement
débutants donc vous m'avez dit averti
c'était le réalisateur tout désigné les
chanteurs tout de même parce que je
présume qu avant de faire cette émission
attrition il a fallu faire le disque et
vous avez pris le parti de prendre des
gens déjà connus ou des gens qui étaient
des amis ou es ce que vous avez déjà
écrit votre compte en pensant à certains
d'entre eux la réponse dans aucune des
propositions non j'écris ça complètement
d'un domaine du rêve et puis quand il a
été fini je me suis fait un générique
idéal il se trouve que ce générique
idéal rejoint la réalité à savoir que
personne ne m'a dit non tous les
artistes dont j'avais rêvé m'ont dit oui
alors par exemple le premier
le premier c'est henri salvador parce
que il avait un rôle disons un peu plus
important que les autres et il avait et
on le verra dans l'émission puisqu'il il
est là tout le temps il est de tous les
plans dans la mesure où c'est lui
compteur il raconte l'histoire la petite
fille et je pense que personne je veux
pas faire de faute de passer de la
pommade à henry mais vraiment je sais il
ya que lui pour chanter aussi bien et
parler aussi bien parce qu'il ya des
grands chanteurs puis les grands
comédiens mais un grand chanteur qui est
aussi un grand comédien c'est plutôt
rare et moi j'ai trouvés qu'henry je
suis content c'est bien et c'est
accepter d'accès et de deux je vais pas
faire ça n'a jamais porté ses
paquet-brenner s'est longtemps mais
c'est pas la raison suffisante je pense
qu'il était vraiment formidable jeu
j'avais vraiment très peur en arrivant
chez lui et il m'a épaulé c'est un peu
le parrain ii d'emilie jolie henry alors
qu'elle second à vagues le second basse
et georges brassens
l'îlot s'il était formidable parce que
il m'a dit bon je suis d'accord mais
apprendre à la chanson avant d'entrer en
studio
jimmy choo pas que la montée me dit non
non non je te fais confiance alors je
suis tombé par terre puis j'ai continué
son a lancé s'ils voulaient j'étais déjà
deux mètres du sol le deuxième jour au
lendemain j'ai appelé julien clerc j'ai
appelé charlebois j'appelais tout le
monde puis ils ont tous dit oui c'était
formidable
j'en suis pas encore revenu au fatah
sort lorsqu'il a fallu faire tous à
mettre tout ça en images
vous avez contacté à nouveau oui ils ont
à nouveau été d'accord oui à 52 futur
hearst histoire l'idée c'est un conte de
fées la réalisation du disque d'un conte
de fées
la réalisation du show c'est un ami zone
30 de fait on fait un brassens m'a dit
j'espère que tu vas quand même pas le
monter sur scène j'ai dit si on me l'a
proposé mais là je voudrais plus le rien
demandé à personne quand même
[Musique]